To close out this video, let's talk about creating blueprints for ray tracing.
So we'll talk about the level blueprint for real-time tests and then also talk about editor
utilities with widgets, which really powerful functionality that you can make use of even
outside of ray tracing.
So the first thing we want to touch upon is that console commands can be used with blueprints
to help optimize visuals such as ray trace reflections, the max distance.
You can use these in the level blueprint to execute the console command and it's just
this execute console command function that you can see in the editor here.
Now a really nice useful tip is that you can dump console commands into the output log,
which will show you all the commands that you can use.
So I'll just show you an example of that now.
So if we're back in our editor, you have a console window at the bottom here.
So you can just type dump console commands and you'll start seeing it up here at the
top.
Now you can go ahead and select that or you can just type in the whole thing.
So I'll just press the up key to go and select it, hit enter.
And then if we go to our output log along the bottom, you'll see everything that's
just been dumped.
So you'll see the command dump console commands and you'll see everything that you have access
to inside of Unreal.
So if you were in your level blueprint, say we just had the previous example, if we had
a begin play and console command, execute console command, you could type whatever console
commands you want that are relevant to your scene in there and they'll fire off when
the level loads.
The last thing to mention in this section is that you can also use the help with console
variables which will give you a complete list of definitions opening inside of a hyperlink.
So a lot of these console commands can be found online as well.
So that should help just really refine what you want your scene to be doing.
We can also use editor utility widgets, which as I mentioned just a couple of minutes ago,
they're very, very powerful and can house a lot of information inside of Unreal.
So we can create editor utility widgets through right clicking in the content browser and
going to editor utilities and then editor utility widget.
So they can be powerful for linking control and editor of the editor itself.
Once opened, the UMG has its own blueprint as well and it allows for custom buttons we
can link in console command.
So to give you an example of this, we can open an editor utility, select some buttons
and assign some console commands to this button.
So if I jump back into the editor and then just go into my blueprint folder, I have this
editor utility here, which I can double click for now.
And you'll see that in the designer at the top right, so this is just the Unreal Motion
Graphics window, the UMG window.
We've added two buttons here, which we've just created from the common palette here.
We've got button zero and button one.
And what we can do in our graph, if we go over to our graph and we see our buttons and
what we can do is we can select the first button.
And then if you see the events tab down in the bottom left hand side here, you can see
the on clicked.
So we'll just click on clicked.
That says on click to button zero.
And then we see button one as well.
Repeat that process on clicked.
And then you can fire off whatever console commands you'd like.
I mean, you can fire off any scripting really.
That's what makes editor utility so powerful.
But in this example, if you wanted to run two different ray tracing console commands,
for example, you could do that.
And then you could just compile and save.
And then in the editor window, if you right click this editor utility and just go to run
editor utility, you've got this little box that appears and you've got these two buttons.
Now you can imagine the functionality where you can pin these editor utilities into your
editor and they have really powerful functionality where you could toggle between different outputs.
You can double click this.
You could add names onto these buttons by adding a text render into there and calling
them, you know, set ray tracing to three or, you know, whatever variables you're playing
with on the console commands.
And then with this functionality, you would have some customizable windows inside of Unreal
just editing the content in a more efficient and streamlined way to try out different variations
for your project.
So hopefully that gives you a good idea about console commands and also using editor utilities,
especially in relation to ray tracing.